[Applaus]
[Musik]
Ende März 2023 löste sich Hiroshi
nishiama ein 50-jähriger leitender
Angestellter von astellas Pharma einem
der größten pharmazeutischen Unternehmen
Japans in Luft auf er tat dies an seinem
letzten Tag in China kurz vor seiner
Rückkehr nach Japan nachdem er 20 Jahre
dort gearbeitet hatte und bald darauf
wurde klar warum er verschwunden war
Nishiyama war von der chinesischen
Polizei verhaftet worden die ihn
Beschuldigte ein Spion zu sein oder
zumindest dass er in Spionageaktivitäten
verwickelt sei das Problem meine Lieben
Zuschauer sind nicht die Anschuldigungen
so zweifelhaft wir sie auch finden mögen
sondern dass er schon der 18 japanische
Staatsbürger ist der seit 2015 in China
verhaftet und angeklagt wurde in diesem
Zusammenhang sind Verdächtigungen und
spionagevorwürfe in diesem Land an der
Tag Ordnung 15 Mai 2023 China verurteilt
amerikanischen Staatsbürger wegen
Spionage zu lebenslanger Haft
interessanterweise betrifft dieser
spionagetrend nicht nur
Einzelfälle die staatlichen Medien haben
Beratungs und
Wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen ins
Visier genommen gegen die von den
nationalen Sicherheitsbehörden
Untersuchungen eingeleitet wurden und
das hat z.B dazu geführt dass China in
der von Oxford analytica durchgeführten
Umfrage zu politischen bei mehreren
multinationalen Unternehmen bereits
weltweit auf Platz 2 der Liste der
Länder mit dem höchsten politischen
Risiko steht nur noch hinter Russland
das erklärt auch das was wir euch schon
oft gesagt haben obwohl China nach wie
vor ein sehr wichtiges Zielland ist
überlegen immer mehr Unternehmen wie sie
ihre Produktion von dort weg
diversifizieren können es mag in den
Medien keine große Rolle spielen aber
die Wahrheit ist nun mal dass die
jüngsten Entscheidungen der chinesischen
Regierung bei vielen multinationalen
Unternehmen die Alarmglocken schrillen
lassen für Europa und Deutschland stellt
China eines der größten wirtschaftlichen
Risiken überhaupt da es ist sogar von
drastischen Änderungen des
spionageabwehrgesetzes die Rede die
viele Unternehmen und Fachkräfte in die
Schusslinie bringen könnte und die Frage
lautet was um alles in der Welt ist in
China los setzt das Regime von Shi
Jinping die spionagegesetze ein um Druck
auf ausländische Unternehmen auszuüben
sie zu bestrafen oder die Beziehung zu
ihnen abzubrechen was könnte das alles
für die wirtschaftliche Zukunft der
sogenannten Volksrepublik China bedeuten
heute werden wir hier visualpolitik all
diese kritischen Fragen beantworten und
zwar gleich nach dem wichtigen
Werbehinweis unseres tollen Sponsors
surfshark denn wusstet ihr dass viele
Firmen wie z.B Airlines ganz
unterschiedliche Preise anbieten können
je nachdem von welchem Land aus man
bestellt bzw ein Ticket Bucht tja aber
zum Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe eines
VPNs überlisten und richtig Geld sparen
surfshar VPN ist dabei ein wirklich
empfehlenswertes und sicheres VPN welch
z.B keinerlei Verbindungsdaten mitlockt
ein Virtual Private Network VPN ist aber
nicht nur zum geldspar fen geeignet denn
es kann einen auch vor so manch größerer
Gefahr schützen die ihm n lauert
natürlich muss man nach wie vor Umsicht
walten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert es in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktion im Netz nachzu
verfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität inets erhöhen z.B
mit dem integrierten cleanb das alle
unerwischten Cookies und Pop-ups blockt
weiterer Vorteile ven ist wie gesagt
dass ihr so tun könnt als wäret ihr an
einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr dann z.B
auch auf Websites und Internetdienste
zugreifen die in dem Land in dem Ihr
gerade seid nicht verfügbar wären ob
daheim oder im Urlaub damit schlagt ihr
Zensur und geblocking ein Schnippchen
Netflix und andereingen die ihre Inhalte
nur in USA Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches Internetfernsehen Ausland
gucken mit surfshar kein Problem aber
das ist noch lange nicht alles denn mit
nur einem surfchar Konto könn wirklich
alle eure Endgeräte im VP registrieren
Handys notebox oder sogar euren Smart TV
so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
politik.de angeht bekommt ihr von
surfsark auch noch einen rabattinhöhe
von 83% und oben dran die ersten 3
Monate gratis den Link zu diesem Angebot
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also nichts vi los besorgt
euch sur und greift damit gleichzeitig
auch uns finanziell unter die Arme das
könnt ihr übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe
der spendenlinks die ich ebenfalls in
die Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind
euch für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit helft ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere Videos zu liefern
so und sobald ihr das alles erledigt
habt lasst uns ins Reich der Mitte
aufbrechen um unsere brennenden Fragen
zu beantworten dazu müssen wir aber
zuerst verstehen wie alles wirklich
angefangen hat also
[Musik]
aufgepasst
die
[Musik]
Verhaftungswelle alles begann im Jahr
2014 kaum ein Jahr nach dem shijimping
der Allmächtige Präsident Chinas
geworden war mit Schlagzeilen wie diese
chinesische Legislative verabschiedet
spionageabwehrgesetz neues Gesetz
definiert Spionage und gibt den
nationalen Sicherheitsbehörden die
Befugnis Eigentum zu beschlagnahmen
dieses neu Gesetz ersetzte das nationale
Sicherheitsgesetz von 1993 und gab den
nationalen Sicherheitsbehörden die
Möglichkeit bei Aktivitäten die ihrer
Meinung nach der nationalen Sicherheit
Schaden Personen festzusetzen und zu
verfolgen es ermöglichte auch die
Beschlagnahmung von Vermögenswert und
Eigentum und das Recht Geräte Geld oder
andere Gegenstände zu konfiszieren die
im Zusammenhang mit Spionage stehen
könnten t shishin Ping mag es eben wenn
alles unter Kontrolle ist so überrascht
es nicht dass nach der Verabschiedung
dieses Gesetzes die Verhaftungen
begnen am 15 Juli z.B wurde der Forscher
hideji Suzuki verhaftet als er ein
Flugzeug zurück nach Japan nehmen wollte
den Grund dafür kannte er nicht er wurde
einfach beschuldigt ein Spion zu sein
während seiner Verhandlung erfuhr er
dass einer der Gründe war dass er einen
Kollegen der ein chinesischer Amtsträger
war gefragt hatte ob er etwas über die
angebliche Hinrichtung seines Onkels
durch kimyong unwisse am Ende gab es
nicht viel zu erzählen aber er wurde
deswegen zu 6 Jahren Gefängnis
verurteilt und die Haftbedingungen nun
davon lassen wir ihn selbst erzählen
das schlimmste waren die ersten 7 Monate
meiner Haft in dem Raum waren die
Fensterläden geschlossen ich dürfte nur
mit Sondergenehmigung 15 Minuten lang
die Sonne sehen ich weinte als ich sie
sah 2017 wurden vier Mitarbeiter von NC
geophysical survey und zwei Mitarbeiter
eines anderen Lokalen Unternehmens
verhaftet und im Jahr 2018 reagierten
die chinesischen Behörden auf die
Verhaftung der kanadischen Huawei
Finanzchefin mengan indem Sie zwei
Kanadier unter Spionageverdacht
Festnahmen obwohl keine Beweise
vorgelegt wurden es handelte sich
schlicht und einfach um eine Geist Name
von Ausländern durch den chinesischen
Staat und die sind nur drei Beispiele
die für viele weitere Fälle stehen denn
das alles war natürlich nur der
Anfang wir haben über die Gefahr die von
ruawei angeht sogar damals ein eigenes
Video gedreht und ich wer es euch
verlinken vor allem in den letzten
Jahren hat die chinesische Regierung
ihre Bemühungen verstärkt ihre Kontrolle
überfast alles zu erweitern sie zieht
all ihre Schlingen immer weiter zu im
Jahr 2021 führte die chinesische
Cyberspace Verwaltung viele neue
datenexportbeschränkungen ein
Beschränkungen die am 1 September 2022
in Kraft traten und schon jetzt vielen
Unternehmen und Fachkräften alle Art das
Leben sehr schwer machen diese Regeln
schrenken allgemein den Zugang zu
unternehmen ein Investoren und Fachleute
wie Wirtschaftsprüfer können
buchhaltungsinformation chinesischer
Unternehmen nicht mehr einsehen
natürlich auch nicht mehr
Patentinformation wissenschaftliche
Zeitschriften und statistische Reihen
aller Art die statistikzensur wurde zu
einem großen Hobby shishinpings das gilt
z.B für die wichtigste Datenbank im
ganzen Land die von der in Shanghai
ansäsigen B Information verwaltet wird
eine riesige und wichtige Quelle für
Wirtschafts und Finanzdaten die bisher
von ausländischen Analysten und
Investoren Regel genutzt wurde nämlich
um festzustellen wie es den chinesischen
Unternehmen überhaupt geht und wie sie
arbeiten das alles wird allerdings
zunehmend
komplizierter in diesem Zusammenhang
wurde 2019 auch ein weiterer forscher
der Universität hokidu festgenommen
momentan werden in China fünf Japaner
unter ganz ähnlichen Spionagevorwürfen
festgehalten vor kurzem wurden
Mitarbeiter der us-beratungsfirma bin
and company in Shanghai verhört bei der
ebenfalls US-amerikanischen
Beratungsfirma minstgroup wurden fünf
Beschäftigte festgenommen und im März
203 kündigte Peking eine Überprüfung der
cybersicherheit gegen das
US-amerikanische Halbleiterunternehmen
Micron Technology an auf die gleiche
Weise stattete die Polizei dem Büro des
nordamerikanischen Netzwerk und
Beratungsunternehmens Cap Vision einen
Überraschungsbesuch ab denn Liebe visual
poliity Community die chinesische
Regierung ist besessen von Daten und
genau das erklärt Nachrichten wie diese
China sperrt Informationen über das Land
in eine Blackbox die vielleicht
wichtigste Maßnahme mit potenziell
weitaus schwerwiegenderen Auswirkungen
kam allerdings mit Beginn des zweiten
Quartals 2023 schaut es euch an China
belegt weitreichende Ausweitung des
spionageabwehrgesetzes am 26 April hat
das wichtigste gesetzgebende Organ
Chinas der sogenannte Nationale
Volkskongress eine sehr bedeutende
Reform des spionageabwehrgesetzes von
2014 verabschiedet eine Reform die bei
Unternehmen Investoren und Regierungen
auf der ganzen Welt die Alarmglocken
schrillen lässt und die Frage ist wieso
was steht in diesem Gesetz nun passt gut
auf denn die Auswirkungen dieser
Gesetzesänderungen könnten viel
gravierender sein als ihr
[Musik]
denkt der finale
Schlag meine Lieben Zuschauer die
jüngsteform des chinesischen
spionageabwehrgesetzes hat viele in
Panik versetzt die Frage ist warum nun
weil diese Reform fünf gravierende
Veränderungen mit sich bringt erstens
wird der Geltungsbereich des Gesetzes
auf alle Dokumente Daten und Materialien
und Gegenstände ausgewartet die nach
Ansicht der Regierung mit der nationalen
Sicherheit und den nationalen Interessen
in Zusammenhang stehen könnten dabei
spielt es keine Rolle ob sie öffentlich
oder privat sind denn in diesem
Zusammenhang definiert das Gesetz
überhaupt nicht was dies konkret umfasst
und welche Bereiche unter den Begriff
der nationalen Sicherheit überhaupt
fallen und was bedeutet das nun also
keine Angst wir werden es uns gleich in
Detail ansehen aber im Grunde bedeutet
es dass alles im Ermessen der Regierung
liegt zweitens die Reform stärkt auch
die Kontrolle über den Cyberspace
drittens erhalten die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden mehr Befugnisse
um das Gepäck und die elektronischen
Geräte von Personen zu überprüfen und zu
beschlagnahmen die ih Verdacht stehen
mit sensiblen Daten zu handeln viertens
müssen alle chinesischen Bürger und
Organisationen jeden Verdacht auf
Spionage melden und riskieren als
Mittäter betrachtet zu werden wenn Sie
dies nicht tun und ihr wisst was das
bedeutet im Grunde nämlich dass jedes
Verhalten als verdächtig angesehen
werden kann wir werden uns hierzu gleich
einige Beispiele ansehen ausländische
Akademiker wie ich werden es jetzt
vermeiden nach China zu reisen wenn es
möglich ist denn Dinge wie Kommentare in
den sozialen Medien könnten in den Augen
der chinesischen Regierung als Beweis
für Spionage angesehen werden Tomoko ako
Wissenschaftlerin an der Universität von
tokioo und fünftens wird jeder Person
gegen die im Rahmen dieses Gesetzes
ermittelt wird die Ausreise untersagt
egal ob es sich um einen Einheimischen
oder um einen Ausländer handelt aber
achtung diese Person muss gar nicht
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden es reicht
einfach nur dass die Regierung oder
irgendjemand glaubt dass diese Person
eine Gefahr für die nationale Sicherheit
darstellen könnte um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben nach Angaben
von Reus hat sich die Anzahl der
Ausreiseverbote zwischen 2016 und 2022
verachtfacht und das war vor der
Gesetzesänderung stellt euch also vor
was diese Reform von nun an bedeuten
könnte aber Moment mal warum eigentlich
hat dieses Gesetz so viele Menschen rund
um den Erdball in Panik versetzt nun vor
allem weil es vollständig in den Betrieb
privat Unternehmen
[Musik]
eingreift das Gesetz spricht nämlich
nicht nur von Staatsgeheimnissen sondern
von jeder Art von Informationen und
Daten das Problem ist natürlich dass
heute unglaublich viele Unternehmen mit
China zu tun haben und dass jedes
Unternehmen um mehr oder weniger gut zu
funktionieren seine Führungskräfte mit
Information versorgen muss sie müssen
nun mal wissen wie sich Ihre Branche
entwickelt welche Vorlieben die
Verbraucher haben wie hoch ihre
Ersparnisse sind welche Patente
veröffentlicht werden was das
Unternehmen selbst entwickelt welche
Daten es von seinen Konkurrenten erhält
und so weiter und so fort allerdings
kann es jetzt schon ein großes Problem
darstellen in den Besitz dieser
Information zu kommen das gleiche gilt
für alle die mit den Unternehmen die
irgendwas mit China zu tun haben
irgendwie verbunden sind
Wirtschaftsprüfer Berater oder Anwälte
wenn sie Ausländer sind müssen sie mit
einer Art von Informationen Arbeiten die
sie ins Gefängnis bringen kann und zwar
nach einem Prozess der im Falle von
Spionagevorwürfen komplett im
Verborgenen stattfindet mit anderen
Worten jeder der in China mit Projekt
oder Unternehmensinformation hantiert
kan nach dem antispionagegesetz wegen
nichts Geringerem als Spionage angeklagt
werden sie müssen nicht einmal mit einem
anderen Land zusammenarbeiten und das
ist ein großes Problem denn praktisch
jeder Geschäftsreisende kann jetzt in
China verhaftet und wegen Spionage
angeklagt werden das gleiche gilt
natürlich auch für die Einheimischen und
verhaftet zu werden ist natürlich eines
der schlimmsten Dinge die einem in den
meisten Ländern der Welt passieren kann
vor allem in Autokratien wie China die
Situation ist noch unklarer geworden und
die Unternehmen sind gezwungen in
vielerlei Hinsicht vorsichtiger zu sein
das neue spionagebekämpfungsgesetz der
KPC sendet ein lautes klares Signal an
die Welt so etwas wie ein privates
Unternehmen gibt es in China nicht die
Staatsmacht behält sich das Recht vor
willkürlich jegliches Eigentum zu
beschlagnahmen geistiges Eigentum zu
stehlen und Daten zu sammeln und nicht
nur das der staatliche Fernsehsender
CCTV hat sogar Beratungsfirmen wegen
angeblicher Schädigung der nationalen
Sicherheit
verklagt um also nicht jederzeit der
Spionage beschuldigt zu werden müssen
Unternehmen Führungskräfte und
Investoren mit den offiziellen Daten
arbeiten die die Regierung
veröffentlicht ohne dass sie versuchen
können auf eigene faustinformation zu
beschaffen und zu sammeln es sei denn
Sie wollen riskieren im Knast zu landen
und das ist nur eine von vielen
möglichen Konsequenzen denn außerdem
kann jede Anschuldigung aus welchem
Grund auch immer dazu führen dass
nationale Sicherheitsbehörden die
elektronischen Geräte und Büros
ausländischer Unternehmen durchsuchen
wodurch Geschäftsgeheimnisse und
geistiges Eigentum aufgedeckt werden
könnten nun was soll ich sagen
angesichts Chinas Erfolgsbilanz in
diesem Bereich da muss man schon sehr
vorsichtig sein logischerweise ist dies
auch in den USA ein Thema das immer mehr
Besorgnis erregt aber generell ist jedes
Land betroffen dessen Wirtschaft eng mit
der Chinas verflochten ist so z.B auch
Deutschland unsere Wirtschaftsführer
müssen ihre goldenen augenwinden
abnehmen und erkennen dass die jüngsten
polizeiraen bei den amerikanischen
Unternehmen B und Minz keine einmaligen
Vorfälle sind sondern Teil einer langen
stolzen Tradition der
Ausbeutung der Kongress sollte ein
Gesetz verabschieden dass die börs
Aufsichtsbehörde ermächtigt den
Geldfluss nach China zu begrenzen das
Vorhaben sollte von beiden Parteien
unterstützt werden und an dieser Stelle
stellen sich viele von euch sicher die
Frage warum eigentlich was hat die
chinesische Regierung davon wenn sie es
auf private information und Daten
abgesehen hat nun wahrscheinlich nichts
das Problem ist im Wesentlichen aber
dass Peking von drei Dingen besessen
ist erstens so argumentiert tangbiao ein
Aktivist Rechtsexperte und Professor an
der chinesischen Universität für
Politikwissenschaften und re den piking
will die Regierung mit all dieser
Kontrolle verhindern dass ausländische
Mächte eine Revolution in China
anzetteln und okay ihr denkt vielleicht
dass das nicht die wahrscheinlichste
Sache der Welt ist aber unabhängig davon
scheint man in Peking geradezu besessen
davon zu sein die Kontrolle zu behalten
und alles zu verhindern was das aktuelle
Regime auch nur ein wenig
beeinträchtigen könnte und wenn alle
Unternehmen an der kurzen Leine gehalten
werden ist das umso besser zweitens will
die Regierung die Berichterstattung über
den tatsächlichen Zustand der
chinesischen Wirtschaft auch
kontrollieren denn die Kische Wirtschaft
ist wie wir alle wissen nicht gerade in
Bestform die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit
bricht alle Rekorde nur die öffentlichen
Investitionen wachsen und der
ausländische Sektor verlangsamt sich
bedeutet dies dass das chinesische
Wirtschaftswunder zu Ende geht nun in
Peking ist man sich sicher dass je
weniger die anderen davon wissen desto
besser und drittens will die Regierung
auch um jeden Preis verhindern dass
Chinas Unternehmens Industrie und
technologiedaten das Land verlassen und
von Konkurrenten im Rest der Welt
genutzt werden schließlich hat man ja
große Erfahrung im Diebstahl von
geistigem Eigentum so aber jetzt fragen
sich viele von euch sicher wie sich das
alles auf die chinesische Wirtschaft
auswirken wird willpcking ausländische
Unternehmen wirklich mit aller Macht
dazu bringen das Land zu verlassen will
man sich nur vollkommen isolieren und
das internationale Geschäft vollkommen
Kappen nun nichts könnte weiter von der
Wahrheit entfernt sein klingt paradox
nicht wahr nun jetzt kommt die
Auflösung tödliche
Umarmung ihr seht also dies ist das
jüngste große Problem das das Regime der
Kommunistischen Partei Chinas den
ausländischen Unternehmen im Land und
auch den einheimischen Unternehmen
selbst bereitet natürlich ist das nicht
der erste Rückschlag in den letzten
Jahren haben wir z.B den Krieg gesehen
den shishin Pings Regierung gegen die
großen chinesischen techunternehmen
entfesselt hat es begann Ende 2020 als
Peking den Börsengang der AR Group
stoppte nachdem jackm kritische Äußerung
getätigt hatte die für Pekings
Machthaber so etwas wie den letzten
Tropfen dargestellt haben von diesem
Moment an startete die
pseudokommunistische Partei eine
Kampagne mit neuen Regeln Geldstrafen
Beschränkungen boykotten und mehr
restriktiver Kontrolle über alle diese
Unternehmen das Ziel die wachsene macht
die diese Konzerne im Land
monopolisieren sollte eingeschränkt
werden vor allem aber ging es darum die
Clans von Shis Vorgängern zu entmachten
denn diese hatten oft die Kontrolle über
die techfirmen shijinpings Clan hingegen
kontrolliert er die Banken und das
Baugewerbe das haben wir bereits in
einem Video
dargelegt
und nicht nur das kurz darauf am 17
August 2021 wurde der Plan für den
gemeinsamen Wohlstand vorgestellt um die
übermäßigen Gewinne zu begrenzen die
viele Unternehmen nach Ansicht der
Regierung erzielten mit anderen Worten
zum ersten Mal seit vielen Jahren nahm
die chinesische Regierung die
Unternehmensgewinne wieder ins Visier
auch diesen Plan haben wir euch damals
in einem eigenen Video vorgestellt und
ich werde es euch verlinken gleichzeitig
begann das Regime auch seine Präsenz in
der Hauptstadt und vor allem im
Management großer Unternehmen zu
verstärken um euch eine Vorstellung
davon zu geben es gibt jetzt sowohl in
staatlichen als auch in privaten
Unternehmen auf der höchsten Ebene sogar
über dem CEO des Unternehmens selbst
einen Vertreter der Partei der die
Unternehmen überwacht und an den
Entscheidungen beteiligt ist aber selbst
das sind nur drei Beispiele zu denen
noch eine ganze Reihe neuer Vorschriften
Regulierungen und die Reform des
spionageabwehrgesetzes hinzukommen die
wir gerade besprochen haben mit all dem
im Hinterkopf stellt sich die große
Frage will die chinesische Regierung
privat Unternehmen wirklich abschrecken
nun das Überraschendste von allem ist
dass dies offensichtlich nicht der Fall
[Musik]
ist all diese Pläne kollidieren frontal
mit den beiden anderen hauptprioritäten
der Regierung China soll zum großen
wirtschaftlichen Maßstab der Welt werden
und vor allem sollen kurzfristig neue
ausländische Investitionen angezogen
werden um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln und
alle Schlaglöcher zu überwinden in denen
sie gerade steckt alle wollen dass wir
mehr investieren es scheint ein bisschen
so als wüsste die linke Hand nicht was
die rechte tut Jörk Wutke Präsident der
Handelskammer der Europäischen Union in
China in diesem Zusammenhang versucht
Chinas Premierminister das Image des
Landes zu verbessern und wird nicht müde
immer wieder zu betonen dass China offen
für Geschäfte ist die chinesische
Regierung hat immer wieder erklärt dass
sie ausländische Investitionen begrüßt
allerdings hat eine Reihe von Maßnahmen
die in letzter Zeit gegen US-Unternehmen
in China ergriffen wurden die
gegenteilige Botschaft vermittelt
Michael hart Präsident der American
Chamber of Commerce in China tja das ist
der große Widerspruch in dem sich die
chinesische Regierung befindet ein
Widerspruch der z.B dazu führt dass in
der Umfrage der amerikanischen
Handelskammer zur geschäftsstimmung in
China zum ersten Mal in den letzten 25
Jahren die Mehrheit der Unternehmen
geantwortet hat dass sie China nicht
mehr als eines der drei wichtigsten
Ziele für Investitionen
[Musik]
ansehen ja das asiatische Riesenreich
wird wegen seines gigantischen Marktes
weiterhin von entscheidender Bedeutung
sein und internationale Unternehmen
werden dort weiterhin viel Geld
investieren aber es scheint immer
deutlicher zu werden dass die
Anziehungskraft schwächer wird ging es
früher darum in China zu investieren um
von dort aus den gesamten Weltmarkt zu
bedienen geht es jetzt nur noch darum
dass Investitionen in China vor allem
den lokalen Markt bedienen sollen die
Strategie scheint jetzt zu sein dass man
in China nur so viel investiert wie
unbedingt nötig und keinen Cent mehr und
wisst ihr was das ist verdammt noch mal
nicht gut für China aber lasst uns doch
um das ganze zu untermauern einen Blick
auf ein paar Daten werfen wie ihr sehen
könnt bricht die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit
in China der Zeit Rekorde unter den
Arbeitslosen sind fast 12 Millionen
Hochschulabsolventen und das obwohl die
Erwerbsbevölkerung des Landes aufgrund
der Alterung in den letzten drei Jahren
um mehr als 40 Millionen Menschen
zurückgegangen ist die Lage ist so
kritisch dass sich die Besucherzahlen in
den Tempeln vervierfacht haben ganz
genau die Hälfte der Gläubigen Besucher
sind junge Menschen die nach 1990
geboren sind und dort für einen Job
beten das ist kein
Scherz die staatlichen Medien haben
ihrerseits eine Kampagne gestartet um
Hochschulabsolventen dafür zu rügen dass
sie keine Jobs im Baugewerbe in der
Landwirtschaft oder im Hotel und
Gaststättengewerbe annehmen zig
Millionen haben vollkommen am Bedarf
vorbeistudiert vor allem human und
Sozialwissenschaften tja anscheinend
braucht es keinen großen Push für
genderwissenschaften damit sowas in
allem Land passiert und vor allem ist
das kein isoliertes Problem die
zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
wächst nicht auf breiter Front die
Verbraucherausgaben erholen sich aber
das verarbeitende Gewerbe ist auf dem
Rückzug und die Gewinne der Industrie
sinken das Einkommenswachstum der
privaten Haushalt ist schwach und die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit liegt nahe einem
Rekord hoch es ist die schlimmste
Wirtschaftskrise in China seit der
Kulturrevolution es ist eine sehr sehr
schlechte Situation wenn die Sache erst
einmal in sich zusammenfällt wird es
überall viel Leid geben hier strenge
Kontrolle behindert eine bessere
Reaktion auf Chinas Abschwung die
Funktionäre machen sich zunehmend Sorgen
um das Wachstum können aber nicht ohne
die Zustimmung des Regierungschefs
Handeln ihr seht es also jetzt
verspricht die Reform des
spionageabwehrgesetzes auch noch Öl ins
Feuer zu gießen Chinas Reformen fangen
an den Unternehmen das Leben äußerst
schwer zu machen und das genau zu dem
Zeitpunkt an dem das Land Unternehmen
und Investitionen am dringendsten
braucht es ist einfach verrückt und
daher werden wir euch auch in Zukunft
über dieses kritische Thema auf dem
Laufenden halten vergesst also bitte
nicht das Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen
falls es euch genauso interessiert wie
uns und jetzt seid erstmal ihr mit eurer
Meinung an der Reihe was denkt ihr lohnt
es sich für westliche Unternehmen
weiterhin in China zu investieren werden
sie ihre Investitionen beibehalten oder
ihr Engagement in den asiatischen riesen
reduzieren wie könnte sich das auf China
auswirken und was würdet ihr tun wie
immer sind wir auf eer Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht etwas dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gebt uns bitte ein
Like und teilt es mit euren Freunden um
es auch mit Ihnen zu diskutieren
natürlich freollen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
unself dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald